le déconfinement entamé en france depuis
le 11 mai dernier a permis un
assouplissement des règles de
déplacement dans le pays des règles qui
aujourd'hui font monter la colère chez
certains français
si le gouvernement a désormais autoriser
les déplacements dans un périmètre de
100 kilomètres sans autorisation
particulière certains français profitent
de la période pour rejoindre leur
famille leur résidence secondaire ou
leurs amis à l'autre bout de la france
des déplacements qui proviennent souvent
des grandes villes classées rouge vers
les campagnes
une attitude qui met en colère de
nombreux habitants de régions classées
vertes qui ont peur que l'épidémie
repartent
c'est le cas par exemple au cap sizun en
bretagne ont des riverains en colère ont
pesté contre l'arrivée des voitures qui
n'était pas immatriculée dans la région
ainsi des tags ont été réalisés à
l'attention de ses visiteurs malvenue
touristes plus de 100km barrez vous
alors comprenez vous la colère des
provinciaux alors moi je délaisse le
thème provinciaux ouais ouais pas
pourquoi je trouve que c'est un timbre
minervois ont dit pas le province on est
les régions maintenant les régions
exactement bawin on le sait surtout les
mecs qui sont tranquilles chez 2 qui
voit des mecs déboulé moi je suis moi je
les comprends et vous moi je moi je les
comprends tout à fait voilà il ya une
règle établie tout le monde doit la
respecter point barre après là où ça me
chagrine c'est le côté barrez-vous lavio
à cesser la violence
on peut très bien dire écoutez chacun
vote chacun doit respecter cette loi et
chacun doit faire preuve de civisme et
puis on verra priori on espère on croise
tous les doigts que le 2 juin tout ça
sera assouplie et on pourra aller dans
tout dans toute la france voilà prenons
notre mal en patience on a quelques
temps encore à attendre
bien sûr oui bonsoir là quand ça tourne
au rejet là je ne deviens compte
effectivement je comprends l'attitude et
c'est particulièrement vrai pour le
tournage du feuilleton demain nous
appartient plus belle la vie
parce que les gens jouent loewert 7 et
marseille c'est des zones vertes
il n'avait pas du tout envie de voir
arriver les histoires de production de
pas raison à son beau sac miu wen a dû
faire un livre blanc de 30 bases sûres
pour dire voilà la position pour dire
voilà voilà on respecte tout on vous
rassure on vous promet on est curieux de
voir arriver elle
vous compliquer en 200 personnes n'a
bien sûr pas 200 personnes weiss en plus
de son mercato
et puis après celle escalade je connais
moi cette bo calcul ça va j'ai déjà
quelques petites notions oui oui oui il
ya déjà eu des brassages de populations
là pendant le pire aux deux mois les
masses répartie et sa pas changer la
couleur de département qui étaient
enlevés est pas passé au rouge pour
autant donc le mans sa panne impact
suffisant pour ce faire face à des
baisses martelly se joue avec le
professeur a donc joué la carte et c'est
toujours les départements qui déverse
toujours ouvert aujourd'hui une enquête
et vert avant on était confiné la cedh
est confiné les gens ont écouté le
professeur annoncé le professeur ragoût
c'est le cousin du professeur raoult
regardait faux paquets des vagues moi je
peux comprendre si quelqu'un est en
verre je peux comprendre qu'il ait jean
coussau en rouge ils ont tous débarqué
je peux convient sur l'armée petit bémol
les plus petites informations sur les
éloges faites attention qui conseille
pas la peine d'aller caillassé la
voiture du maquis et matricule 1 an 95
78 sûr parce que maintenant les plaques
tu les changes plus donc ça se trouve
c'est un mec qui vient acheter une
bagnole à un gars et vous avez 4 et
habitants et bien sûr je tire de départ
petit conseil au taux de 1 entendu ça
fait toujours du bien
je vous rappelle celle que tout ce week
end encore merci et on parlera de la
fiat
merci c'est important oui j'ai raté je
suis pas vraiment d'accord en fait
d'abord je remarque que les parisiens se
sont fait super u et fin mars vous savez
un fanny mars au début du confinement
unilingue olala monde il ya 20 % des
parisiens qui sont cassés c'est pas mon
cas parce que moi j'ai pas pu que je
suis resté à paris
mais voilà et pour autant il n'y a pas
eu une sorte de vague de virus comme ça
dans les zones où ils sont allés ça
c'est la première chose et ensuite on ne
sentait pas interpréter les cartes en
fait parce que les cartes de la zone
rouge c'est pas parce que le virus
circule plus
c'est juste parce que l'arrêt l'erea son
plein c'est ça donc en fait moi je vois
pas le problème vos journaux aujourd'hui
il ya une règle il faut pas y aller donc
moi j'y vais pas mais sur le principe on
risque pas plus en fait si on est
parisien dalle en province qu en
province et d'ailleurs les clusters
aujourd'hui son province ans ils sont
pas à paris ils sont ailleurs le trésor
à vous djire a dit ça m'a fait beaucoup
de bien votre retour mais vraiment ça me
change de l'équipe là parce que la
chaîne était devons faire craquer
les personnes qui râlent ils devraient
plutôt nous féliciter d'avoir respecté
pendant si longtemps lui rapporte quoi
être bougé d'un after sûr que si ça on
aurait pu bouger rond plus trompe le
confinement et maxime l'a pas entendu
là-dessus je comprends pas parce que
pendant le conflit des années quoi je
suis allé dans le pack wii
alors j'ai respecté toutes les règles en
vigueur mais après cette règle des 100
km est le plus symbolique qu'autre chose
à partir du moment où les citadins mais
ce mec que les choses et la sécurité
nécessaires
après ça peut même relancer l'économie
locale si tu vas à gauche ou à droite
mais l'année là n'est pas le problème
vous avez compris ce que j'ai dit non
soit il ya eu plusieurs idées dans la
phrase en kabyle c'est très souple sur
la situation
bon allez on va retrouver le soin sujet
chaud au bout du rouleau
oh oui à 76% voilà la colère je suis
comme vous mois chauds comme le public
une fois de plus fait parler 76%
jean michel meyer fait partie des 24 %
et je vous le dit jean michel mercier
n'a tort parce qu'un jour le public va
vous tomber dessus